so really what I wanted to do is just
mix science fiction with Africa and
that's what that's what district nine is
nobody comes back late at night anymore
they've more security the government
noticed that they were moving into new
areas that's when things started to get
out of hand you know and it's like you
can miss the whole social and cultural
relevance and depth to it but I think
the best sci-fi always has that it
always has a deep deep basis you know
some kind of deep mythical thing that's
talking to you the real deepest level
even if you miss it don't be long yeah
they spend you so much money to keep
them here when they could be spending it
on other things
at least they're keeping them separate
from us the film in in a nutshell I
think is about segregation the idea of
two races sort of meeting head-on and
and you know the the Powder Keg
situation that that provided in South
Africa
you know when I started making the film
I was very very very aware of the fact
that if I made something that felt
burdened and kind of you know overly
political and preachy I'd end up in not
a good place for a first time director
so I very actively decided to make a
phone that was satirical and and really
is more of a ride it is it's a Hollywood
journey that we take with this character
but it's set against a very serious and
you know politically charged background
a lot of badging started to happen they
must just go I don't know it all at a
mass a scope breadth the breaking point
people are living in fear there's a
corporation that has being tasked with
providing housing and providing you know
medical aid and food and everything to
these aliens and in return for that work
they you know like good humans always do
go after the sort of the corporate and
capitalistic interests of what they can
what they can profit off of from the
aliens I go with the technology and
everything else this is got the markings
they off of so it's definitely alien but
it's another way on the one hand it
looks as though they're this kind of UN
you know humanitarian service which
obviously everybody knows that they're
not and and then at the same time
they're kind of reverse engineering a
lot of the technology because they have
the exclusive sort of patents to you
know the ability to patent the
technology
the story is a very personal story about
this guy who goes from you know from one
side of the spectrum to the complete
other side he has a very familiar
routine he has things that he believes
you know the system works this way and
as long as you follow the rules
everything will work and the the sort of
helpful thing of course is once he wants
you dealing in district 9 and you're
dealing with the the creatures
themselves that really challenges
everything you kind of thought you knew
about how things worked he's sort of
indirectly racist when it really gets
down to the core level the core of his
of his being he actually turns out to be
a good guy another life form has come
from somewhere else but there's a
connection even though there's very
different you still couldn't put these
these creatures in these humans together
it's not a politically correct kind of
form where oh look now you see we were
all meant to live happily these are very
different creatures they have very
different habits and cultural beliefs
but he finds that common element you
know he finds a common element that you
might you might want to call it humanity
it's a common consciousness
I just want everyone watching this to
learn from what has happened it asks
that kind of question of what what what
what do you mean what do you mean what
am i what do you mean let's not talk
about that just blow something up you
attacked and you defended and you you
know in the end it's like what you know
fifty thousand years later
[Music]
you